welcome all and congratulations on a
very beautiful piece of work I just told
my colleagues if we can get through this
without me huddling up it'll be a
miracle although you're down at the
other end I'm going to start ladies
first Rosie and skill question when we
met I told you that when I was about 20
when I read Vera Britain's book the
first time and it made a very profound
impact on me and you said it was the
same for you I wonder if you could tell
us what impelled you to bring this to
the big screen yes good morning
everybody and thank you very much for
coming along to join us for this um yes
I think I was just always very moved by
what is by Vera Britain's what would is
essentially a very loving and moving act
of remembrance on her parts in the book
testament of youth for those she lost in
world war one which obviously feels very
apt in the centenary now and of course
it was it was an elegy not just for the
young men lost in the First World War
but all all youth lost in all wars and
at the heart of it is this indomitable
spirit Vera Brittain who who goes
through this extraordinary rites of
passage journey and all the youths and
hopes and dreams that she has and then
goes through difficult times and
extremists and yet nothing makes her
give up and she she she lives through it
and and keeps running in the race and
doesn't give up and I think it was this
quintessential rites of passage story
about going through the worst the world
has to offer and yet not giving up which
always really moved me thank you James
we know you're very experienced as a
documentarian and in television drama
but this is your first feature film and
it's certainly a big ones and big one to
tackle
I'm going to assume that a part of the
appeal for you was that this wasn't the
typical if there is such a thing war
film but that you're really this is
about the hearts and the minds and the
emotions I think I think that's right I
mean one of the things that as a
director I look for our films subjects
that talk about the sort of universal
human condition and one of the great
things that resonated for me as soon as
I read the script was that this isn't
just a period film it's a film about
ambition love grief survival courage and
those things speak to us now and I think
one of the things I hope the film
achieves is that it resonates with an
audience it's kind of tucked it's like a
touchstone on some of the great
experiences that everyone will
experience in their life and it's
incredibly important that drama and
filmmaking sets up that as a scenario as
a kind of example for people to get
through and I think it moved me
tremendously Thank You Colin I wondered
before you got in front of the cameras
if you had all had a chance to hang out
did you have rehearsal time did you do
improvisation --zz did you find some way
to bond because you're so compelling as
these we unnatural as these devoted
school buddies well as graders we got
the chance to give it a rehearsal with
it with James before starting which
which is invaluable and rare in film
industry at the minute and I think we're
lucky as well as James and cast it very
well because I think we naturally got on
and I think during our own individual
research and with the letters that these
that these people wrote themselves
between each other and understanding
exactly what the bond was between them
and such a tumultuous time was I think
it was was important and coming in with
those connections coming in with those
feelings and coming in very much with
the Judy and a dedication to these
people and I think that was paramount
and I think that reflected really then
when we got on set together and when we
felt it you know I think it did feel
like a very special special moments you
know it shows thank you kit having
originated the role of Albert in War
Horse at the beginning of your career I
assume you were pretty well steeped in
the the World War 1 experience but I
wondered what particularly appealed to
you in this one and in playing role and
what kind of a different experience it
yeah I think I've always but always been
very interested by this war and I think
a lot of young people are actually as I
was growing up I I was fascinated and
wanted to study the war poets and
actually read this book at school and so
with warhorse it was a you know it's my
first job I wanted to turn anyway but it
was a great role that um it was it was
that extra special piece because it was
about a young man going through the
First World War and then when this came
up and I read the script it was so it
was such a so it was so it was such a
beautiful kind of adaptation of of the
book that I'd grown up with
so and and and the character that I knew
quite well that I found it a real
no-brainer to want to play someone who
actually existed and I had so much
research material for in letters and in
the book that it it seemed it seemed
like you know it seemed like an honor to
be able to be given a real person from
history which had not played before
Thank You Taryn um it was there a point
for you where you had to let thinking
about the real Edward go and just go
with the script and go with the did you
take it all in to begin with in that at
gora were you ever mindful of the real
boy and how young he was and well I
think in terms of your your desire to do
justice to the story you never really
let go of the sense that it was a real
person but you know these were people
who were around a hundred years ago so
aside from from these letters and photos
there's no you caught you can't watch
footage and mimic their mannerisms and I
think as well personally I like
performances that I'd rather see an
interpretation of a character than an
impression you know because I think it
normally is a little bit more more
heartfelt but I'm sort of echoing what
these guys have said really I think
you're always you you never you never
fit you never forget that you're playing
a real person especially when they went
through something so horrific and I hope
we've done justice to the memory thank
you okay who's got question let's get
this gentleman a microphone and then the
gentleman down here and then the lady
behind him okay
go sir hi I'm Daryl Schmidt from the
Scottish Sundy Post newspaper oh as
Rosie mentioned there is a hundred years
since the first world war the outbreak
and I wondered if that gave or the
anniversary has had added poignancy to
the free young actors from actually
working on this film engrossing yourself
in the period and whether you find
yourself sort of thinking well it's 100
years since Edward and Roland you know
showing up went off the wall it's
there's going to be a lot coming out
about the First World War perceive it
being the centenary I think it was
interesting about the First World War as
it still feels very present to us it
being a hundred years ago it was the
first mechanic you know mechanical war
mechanized war was so different from
anything but from before it still feels
and I think again talking about to young
people being interested in this movie I
think at school a lot of a lot of young
people get very obsessed with the First
World War because it still feels so
relevant I think that's what's
interesting it doesn't feel to me it
being a centenary ago I think it's
important to revisit it being a hundred
years on and to investigate it but I
always feel it it being the first modern
war if it doesn't feel quite that long
ago strange
hello my name's Barney Bolton from the
national student this question could
apply to Verizon people on the panel but
I'd like to focus on James and KITT if
possible James you've crafted some of
the most cinematic television of recent
years and Kate you've starred in some
incredibly high-end television I just
wondered how different is this
experience of making something for the
big screen now television is also so
cinematic and we're told it's now
merging is it much of a different
experience from both our directing and
acting point of view um well the shoot
surprisingly I mean one of the big
changes I mean to shoot the shoot itself
is pragmatic and pragmatically kind of
quite similar to television
I mean you've got not a lot more time
you know the money you have to expand a
scale to cinematic vision so everything
feels very Thai I think where it feels
very different to television is the
amount of care that amount of time you
have to lavish the care before you start
filming you know as a director you come
on board 18 months I mean you know you
may not in prep for 18 months but you're
sort of working with the script with the
writer with the producer quite a long
time for you shoot so it's really in my
bones by the time I film and also at the
end after the shoot where you're editing
as well is incredibly detailed and
incredibly examined so it's absolutely
the top of its optimum power whereas in
television again the sort of schedule
dictates budget dictates that you sort
of at some point have to draw a line and
move on and one of the things I love one
of the great thrills for me was actually
when the monitor was put up on the first
day of the shoot and it had that
cinematic big rectangle and I oh my god
I'm really doing the real thing it was
really exciting journey over the moon
about that
so those things always very exciting as
a film director yeah I think the budget
for TV has gone up so much in recent
years that as as far as walking onto a
set there isn't a huge difference that
I've noticed working on a TV show with
it with it with a very large budget the
only difference for me being is that
from character development especially in
this movie you have to tell a lot about
who the character isn't a much shorter
space of time you don't have the luxury
of 10 episodes and maybe however many
seasons to kind of it's it's about get
your character across and who it is and
the important things you want to say
with it with without the luxury of time
and I think that's the difference for me
thank you and lady behind you my name is
Albertina I'm from the press association
is a question for kit I'm I wondered if
you return to the war poetry that you'd
studied at school for this role and if
it helped you understand how Ronin might
be feeling especially when he returns on
leave that time um yes I did return to
the war poetry I had and when I looked
at my bookshelf had a surprising amount
sort of war warper anthologies from
school with all my old school note
annotation which was embarrassing but it
it did help and I I mainly refer to I
think we all did
the letters the you know because we read
testament of youth but I think what was
really even more emotionally useful for
us was there was letters from a lost
generation which is an amazing research
tool to have as an actor actually
hearing our characters words so that was
the main thing that I used but yeah it
was it was it was lovely to be able to
revisit all those incredible poems from
the first world war that I hadn't picked
up in so long thank you
hi evaporate over from chicken newspaper
and - Oscar : and turn about when you'd
discovered the book and how what do you
think about it and how much did you use
it during do you think thank you
I hadn't actually come across the book
before um coming across the script I
sort of read it first and then when I
came on board I I began to read the book
um and for me it was it was an area that
I wasn't I hadn't really grown up being
educated on the first world war and it
felt and like a bit of an alien world to
me so so I thought like I did have to
become a little bit of mark spinet and
again I find that is from a lost
generation that others there were
themselves extremely useful just being
able to read their ladders essentially
um him well he's not going to be their
voice in this in this film
and so what's what struck me was was was
a big element of what of what the books
about what of what and the films about
know what the war and was partially
about was was youth and I was lost and
that essentially this part of the youth
that was lost as a part that we know in
the standings are very very privileged
to have and if you take that section of
youth out of your upbringing it
it it makes life very very difficult
very almost impossible in terms of an
emotional point of view and I think I
was so impressive about Vera Britain's
journey on which as I say gets across
phenomenally in the film is the part
overcome the part two and try to pick up
your life after what you've lost
and she lost a massive part of her youth
and that and that to me is what that was
what the film really really gets across
particularly to our generation and the
people who have been through it or who
know were very close to people who have
been through it you're nodding in
agreement Taryn would you like to add
something no I'm actually just thinking
I have no hope of coming out with
anything as profound as that in terms of
the book and for me in my character
I found the I found a lots of the
earlier parts of the book very useful
where Alyssa talks about her and Edward
and lists here look I'm still in
character where Vera talks about a
relationship with Edward going up and
and something that James said very early
on about how he wanted it to feel like
to come because because this is the
first time I've ever played apart I
think that's not the present day so in
order to try and get a feel of how
people held themselves then and behaved
but also to keep hold of the fact that
these are just for young people sneaking
off to sort of play away from their
parents and I think and I think actually
at reading testament of youth and
hearing Vera's words and her affection
for her brother helped massively in
forming the nature of the relationship
between Edward and Vera because they're
fantastically close and I remember James
saying that you know it should almost
feel they're like twins so testament of
youth is very very useful in that
respect gentlemen back there hi guys um
first of all congratulations on a
beautiful piece of cinema obviously this
is a film about loss and we're sorry to
be denied a beautiful leading lady this
morning so I'm wondering if perhaps
styling with kit you could just tell us
a little bit about
working with someone as talented and
magnificent as Alistair obviously is
yeah I mean it's obvious from what
you've seen she's incredibly I mean I
don't even want to say talented because
it's that's such a cliche but she's
amazing person to work opposite she's so
detailed in what she does and so on
point with everything she asks about
every scene that as an actor working
opposite her you never feel in danger of
the scene going flat I had met her once
before previously on a different movie
we did but we never got to work together
so we become friends but we hadn't she
had a scene and that was kind of a
strange place to be in but yeah I mean I
can I can just say how you know she's
deeply missed today we're all very good
friends and I got you know I think she's
she's fabulous she's off taking over the
world which is why I have about seven
films she's finished sensitive actually
at this time on on earth there is no
film Alyssa pecans yeah I mean I can
only echo what KITT said I actually
wasn't familiar with Alyssa's work
before working with her and I think it's
partly to do with the the fire in us of
the character she plays but the first
time the camera turns you kind of sort
of the cool cut come from and she is you
know the only the only phrase I can use
to describe her as a force of nature
she's so diligent so hard-working and
it's in a second language
yeah it's really quite astonishing and I
actually have to confess haven't seen
the film in its entirety yet but just up
just from having shared a scene with her
I know the term it will be quite
something to behold yeah she's up she's
extraordinary and again I can I can only
absolutely agree with that as well we
all had our moments and with very
special movements throughout the film
and they did feel special when you came
to them I think in your head before you
should have seen you've always got a
feeling about it you've always got an
impression about it but it's a uni every
get but truly and unemotionally whenever
you live in it and it felt like we were
living it with
Alessia that's that's what was that's
what felt so special about it because
she she inhabited and there in every
respect in a truthful and an honest and
it in such a detailed way but I think as
an audience you you're absolutely pulled
along in the journey with her and you
feel everything she feels because I
genuinely believe she she really did
feel like when she was what she was
doing it James you had such an
interesting mix of young actors and and
I shall I say veterans I mean I thought
something to me Dominic's still a young
man it's um did you find the theme the
more seasoned actors were sort of
motherly and fatherly to the younger
ones yes I mean at one level absolutely
yes but you know these guys seem so on
top of it I mean I have to tell you you
know that it was never had an experience
like this where you know working with
young cast they seemed so at ease
with the with the challenge that they
face I mean I just returned to Alissa
briefly I mean she you know she doesn't
exhibit any of the insecurities either
on set or behind the scenes that you
know your leading lady leading man can
have I mean which is totally
understandable cuz the burden is on you
you know a piece you carry the film to a
large extent and she seems so sort of I
think I have a theories because she was
a role you know she was a ballerina
they're all Swedish ballet that has sort
of been partly instilled in her this
sort of absolute confidence that she can
go out there and perform her and you
know and I think we all respect you know
we all felt that I mean they set the
tone of the set and you know Dominique
and Emily I'm around the Richardson and
these guys I mean we all wanted to be
there for each other but also for her
and but she felt so in control that um
there was a wonderful ease during the
filming from everyone and that just
meant it was more like a kind of family
I really I mean that sounds like a
cliche but but we really were incredibly
at ease with each other
you've filled me with national pride
this way and I just wanted to ask him
and it concerns me that what how you
felt about the fact that it was she she
does she's not part of this British
collective memory of the war and with a
remembrance everything and I'm wondering
how it first had that affected to you
when you were in the choice of her and
then had that sort of how that played
into working with her you know you know
as a director of course you know you
look for national characteristics what
you what you really look for is someone
who can transmit the key emotion the key
emotions of the film and what Alyssia
has is sort of beyond national
boundaries you know she has a luminosity
it's sort of a fire and a sense of
tragedy in her acting that the you know
surpasses any you know it's just a gift
it's a real gift and another thing to
remember is that actually the film is
about British loss but as she is seen
with a German officer who's dying and
that's an international story you know
every most countries in Europe lost
enormous amounts of people so you know
of course for doing a British story but
you know you wanted to speak as very
Britain would have wanted it to you know
be on the channel and out there and so
this year I think she still has
something a bit other about her which
hopefully will help in international
audiences relate to this tragedy lady in
the front row could you pass with
microphone Thanks and Jan Gilbert for
flicks and the city this is for kit and
obviously audiences know you best for
John Snow and the different characters
of course very different characters
Roland and John although they do have
similarities are both men who are very
much bound by duty and honor they both
attracted to strong real women and
they're both have to grow up very
quickly because of circumstances around
them so I wonder if you could tell us
apart from the schoolboy poetry if how
you prepared for that role of role and
how you got into his head and how that
compared to when you first got the role
of Jon Snow and how you prepare to that
I think the thing that James pushed me
towards constantly while on set
I have a tendency to go for you as an
actor I do not occur quite inward or I
don't really add and what James was
always pushing me towards was that this
young man is a charming young man he's
full of confidence he's 19 years old and
he's at that age where he knows he's
good at everything he's that he's
mastered everything at school he's and
all the top grades he's won all the
awards and it was that I I mean if there
was a difference if the way I got into
Rowland was that he was very sure of
himself in seducing Alicia and Alicia
there we go
Fira
in seducing Vera and I think that that
that was one of the main things for me
was I hadn't played a role like that
before
maybe the the as it goes on he and we
see a change in him and he becomes very
troubled by what he's seen but at the
start he's so light compared to anything
I played and I think that was the right
way to push me for James and I think it
was it was quite relieving to play in a
lot of ways having played a different
character from that for so long how did
it compare to to when he first got the
role the job so may prepare better um
that was so long ago now I was trying to
think about that the other day yeah a
well it was it was I think it again like
I said before preparing for John you've
got a template there now you know that
you know everything that is written it
goes in a certain way I step into that
role that I've prepared five years ago
and can't remember what choices or why I
made them but with Roland he still feels
very fresh to me and and I think he yeah
I think the way I stepped into him was
to try and remember what it was like to
be 19 for a start because I'm now 27 so
I'm playing guy a lot younger than
myself and remember what that excitement
of your first love is and
it was sort of stepping back in time a
bit to a cockier sure a version of
myself if that's at all possible Carlin
I was wondering if you had outdone any
I'm practicing being blind yes I
contacted the plane butter in GK and
Charlie who and apart from the
experience I had with them are fantastic
fantastic Charlie I didn't realize that
there's so many when given you care the
motivator of their help and should I
think and buy I took myself off on the
trailing than to Brighton where there
are better salaries both of you to an
interview some of their some of their
residents there I was very keen to
interview someone who had possibly been
blinded in World War two and possibly
someone who was younger around my age
who had been blinded recently and and I
did I got the two perspectives or not
the perspectives of time and the very
raw and recent perspective from from a
younger guy but when I walked in they
they decided that they were going to
treat me I was I recently acquired blind
resident so whenever I come in they and
they put a blindfold on me and I was and
I was given a tour of the building and
taken in as a resident there um for so I
think it's mostly spend about maybe five
or six hours as a blind person and they
brought me to the workshops and I was
making things they brought me to the gym
they brought me and the kitchen to try
make a cup of tea and my my responses to
the artist song who had vision and then
taken away was was was surreal everyone
had a caller I just convinced that the
person taking me around was was wearing
a pink cardigan
and she wasn't just a Korean jumper you
know I went into a room we sat down have
a cup of tea I was convinced we were
sitting fierce in a mirror
there wasn't a mirror in the room
because I said it after we had had the
experience they took me on the same tour
and around the building again but with
my sight and to me that was a value you
know it was it was it was tough and it
did a lot of things to me mentally and
also the people I spoke to is
particularly the guy who lost his sight
recently it was it was still very raw
and very recent and so it gave me a real
real close to us too as to what what
that would feel like
and for someone of our time and and and
you know what I think I you know try to
utilize out within the film but also as
a life experience I think it was
something that was really unique
gentlemen back here I still don't know
from scoring something post just hearing
Colleen speak there and I thought the
film did it brilliantly were almost with
very few words well it showed her Veera
brought home her experience of the war
and then when she returned home
everything around us seems rather twee
in Pat I wonder if you the actors had a
similar experience working on this film
in that you've immersed yourself into it
so deeply that when you go on to the
next job it's almost you know it feels
not quite as big was that feeling I
think of a condign on any job that you
do thank you you invest yourself in it
so much you um try to dedicate yourself
to it 110%
I think and that if you've done it right
you should have that feeling afterwards
something wrong if you haven't maybe you
know you have to have the calm down and
you have to have a feeling of missing it
I think or you know and and yeah
certainly haven't you know we shot the
last day or for example your when we
shot one of the things were which were
you know a key scene for your character
like the blind scene and which we've
done in the addition as well and it
feels like a moment gone unique you know
get it once we filming
then it exists forever on on on the
screen and so put your personal
experience of it is kind of gone and
then when the movie wraps all the people
and everyone attached it are going to
but then as an actor you have to pick it
all up and go on to the next one and put
that away in a little she kissed
somewhere I found this um just quickly
on that I found this movie I missed this
movie afterwards is the way we shot it
was unique to anything I've ever done
before is incredibly liberating with it
you know I wasn't quite used to always
being blocked in and here's your mark
and there's your and with this you were
given free reign and we had a wonderful
camera crew and a brilliant director who
can a great focus but er who could who
could give you free rein to be more to
be more free in your body and I missed
that on the next job I went on to and I
noticed how much I did and Taryn went
off to drive fast cars and play with
gadgets didn't you I was actually just
before yeah it was um yeah I went off to
be Tom Hardy's boyfriend in the crazy um
yeah but it in answer to your question
as well I think you know the the
extremity of what these young people
went through meant that it did have it
did have a more significant way and if
ever we could have missed that more
significant way when we first met Rosie
and James their passion for it
and their real sort of very tangible
sense of who these people were and
almost the kind of very personal
affection for them was kind of in
infectious really and you couldn't help
but slot into that so yeah you know it
yeah you did feel it afterwards because
it was these work these were were real
were real people and we were trying to
recreate their experiences as faithfully
as possible
Frank we just have time for one more
question so the lady here as soon as did
you have some kind of boot camp to make
you better so just before and did you
discover something about it first of all
where you didn't know like are you doing
research James actually said unless you
do ten laps you're not actually laughs
in the first I mean I think for Terran
particularly because you were the eighth
apple you had a lot of scenes in the
military hospital on the west in which
we built especially and that you know we
made sure that that had the color
element in mud everywhere and plenty of
blood and plenty I mean you know it was
an appalling place I mean I did a big
documentary in Auschwitz and the closest
in terms of the architecture and the
kind of suffering I've ever come across
was the sense of what happened in these
huge hospitals near the Western Front
and you know there was an anesthetized
amputations taking place there were
people with mustard gas victims I mean
thousands people dying but piles of
bodies and I I'm sure for Terron that
hopefully we provided a kind of
environment where he could feel
something truly truly truly disgusting
yeah yeah so it was an absolutely all of
those scenes which you guys have seen
with all the mud and the blood and the
sweat and the tears and all that it
really was unpleasant to film and so it
should have been I think you know I mean
it should have the penis as unpleasant
as possible because it was never going
to come anywhere near to so the reality
button but yeah you had a big moment
kitten you went in the mud and you're
kind of seen in there she's dying in the
rain yeah I nearly drowned
it was just like yeah without what that
wasn't fun it was lying in mud getting
sort of rain tower waterboarded it was a
bit yeah it was great well I know we
have to let team Testament go on their
next film festival mission but I want to
thank you all for joining us and I want
to tell you guys here's where I start
puddling up it ends with vera promising
the men she loved that they would not be
forgotten and I think she'd be so proud
that you're taking them their memory
into the next century thank you very
much
you
you